this is a story you might find really
strange to hear and rest assured it's a
very strange story for me to tell you
it's about the Spanish Foreign Minister
Donald Trump suggested to Spain that
they deal with the migration from Africa
to Europe by building a wall across the
Sahara Desert Donald Trump also
suggested that quote the Sahara border
can't be bigger than our border with
Mexico so let's actually look at a map
if you're watching on TV or on YouTube
you might notice here that the Sahara
Desert is in Africa not in Europe it
spans roughly ten countries none of
which are Spain Trump references and we
can keep this up Trump references the
Sahara border which also makes no sense
since the Sahara isn't really a border
it's not exactly clear what Donald Trump
means by that this would make it very
difficult for Spain to build a wall
across legally speaking and it also as
you can tell is very very big it happens
to be more than 3,000 miles across which
is more than 50% longer than the
us-mexico border that Trump was
referring to and then lastly as if we
need more reasons for why this makes no
sense Donald Trump seems to have no idea
whatsoever that Spain's economic
problems which I guess is what he was
addressing predate the so-called
immigration crisis in Europe and
hilariously there there is actually
something called a Saharan wall it's a
project that's underway it's called the
great green wall but it's not a wall
meant to stop immigrants from coming
through it's a wall of trees meant to
stop climate change to mitigate climate
change not immigrants I'm actually
shocked that Trump hasn't just called
for a wall to be built around all of
Africa right that seems based on his
immigration ideas around skin colour the
wall he he would more likely be
interested in I mean just to take a look
at history though the Arabs did invade
Spain in the year like 700 AD so you
like that and occupied it for quite a
while it could do it there there is
historical precedent here of course with
the Arabs be coming from Africa at this
point is another relevant question but
not one I think that Donald Trump is
equipped to answer at this time yeah and
the Strait of Gibraltar between Spain
and
go it's only like ten miles long you
could swim that out long enough oh good
enough swimmer could definitely swim
swim across that if we're really
thinking about walls to build maybe
Trump should propose one up the entire
Pacific Ocean to stop trade with China
right in the same way that one with
Mexico would stop anybody from coming in
this is what you get when you have
someone who hasn't read a book in his
adult life has no genuine curiosity
about the world and in addition is born
with a silver spoon in his mouth and
starts a business with a small loan of
just a million dollars from his dad this
is how you get to this level of
ignorance and Donald Trump has said and
done very dumb things during his
presidency so far but this is a level of
political and geographic idiocy that I
just didn't think was possible for a 70
year old college-educated adult in the
United States I think the Sahara Desert
should pay for the wall what about you
Lee yeah they're you by the way who
would even pay for it in that case right
and actually maybe that's the most this
is kind of a just a story pointing out
how dumb the people representing us are
maybe the question should be is this
simply ignorance is it insanity or is it
dementia right because Trump did take
that dementia test he was able to tell a
lion and a camel apart so that proves
that that he's fine obviously according
to him so maybe he is truly this
ignorant and I don't know how you defend
this even if you're one of trumps
strongest supporters right like don't
you have to say okay listen I defend the
guy because I like his trade policy but
that was one of the dumbest things I've
ever heard of it would they would just
deny that it ever happened or they say
that he'd be a private conversation
between Trump and the Spanish Foreign
Minister fake news that's what I tell
you please please tell me that history
will not look back kindly at this guy I
I need to believe that just to make it
through to the next day and I'm really
struggling because I worry that a
hundred years from now this guy's legacy
will be whitewashed to such a degree
that he'll be sort of wrapped up as he
was another one of those late 2000s and
early 1990s and early 2000s
residents who yeah you know he didn't do
great but he didn't do bad
yeah I mean George Bush now is being as
being seen by some in a positive light I
mean I did after all give Michelle Obama
a piece of candy yes that's true so the
war crimes there were in Iraq the
economic downturn that's all forgiven
it's all seemingly forgiven no and
that's a real and we've talked about
that just because we point out that even
George Bush had a certain amount of
basic decorum that he adhered to and
whatever else we're not in any way
exculpating Bush's disastrous foreign
and domestic policy it's really really
important to make that point